le musée de la fondation de Coubertin
métal honneur Jean-Michel Fichot le
sculpteur contemporain enrichit le lieu
d'une centaine de ses œuvres depuis
avril sculpture mais aussi art graphique
ou en feu l'exposition fiche aux
sculptures paroles et regardent
l'artiste retrace plus de 40 ans de
travail
un certain nombre de pièces qui
commencent par les pièces des années 80
où on a ce que j'appelle les enfers et à
partir de là j'ai commencé à travailler
donc la déformation et c'est un petit
peu le lien
dans tout mon travail un lien
transversal ou je déforme et où je
cherche différents points de vue c'est
de d'avoir un passage d'une sculpture
qui est relativement figurative et
classique à quelque chose qui va évoluer
vers une forme plus ou moins abstraite
grâce à cette déformation c'est plutôt
ce mouvement qui m'intéresse des œuvres
qui sont pleinement inscrites dans le
discours du musée à travers son parcours
dans la galerie d'exposition le jardin
des bronzes ou encore le morceau de
Coubertin le visiteur découvre un
panorama de la sculpture de la fin du
19e siècle à nos jours c'est des oeuvres
qui sont à la fois classiques mais
également très très moderne par leur
déformation et leur répétitions donc
c'est un artiste qui utilise des
techniques très très traditionnelles
mais qui en fait quelque chose de très
moderne et qui s'inscrit donc dans la
l'histoire de la sculpture contemporaine
le discours de l'exposition
insiste aussi sur la technique de
création pour des sculptures et c'est
vrai que nous sommes un lieu à la
Fondation Coubertin qui est un lieu de
technique artisanale et de technique
d'artisanat d'art donc c'est aussi sur
ce message là qu'on insiste au-delà de
l'esthétisme de ces œuvres l'artiste
s'inscrit également dans l'actualité
certaines de ses œuvres expriment le
ressenti de son époque comme la
destruction du Temple de balsamine à
Palmyre ou encore les massacres à
l'enclave de Zeppa en Bosnie en 1995
j'étais dans mon atelier j'écoutais donc
la radio et à ce moment-là
j'entends ce massacre et symboliquement
j'ai voulu faire quelque chose donc j'ai
réalisé cette pièce donc en terre
Jean-Michel Fichot avait déjà collaboré
avec la fondation de Coubertin en 2016
pour la fonte de la sculpture femme
feuille maintenant exposée à
Bures-sur-Yvette le processus est décrit
étape par étape dans le jardin des
bronzes l'exposition est à retrouver les
samedis et dimanches de 14h à 19h
jusqu'au 16 juillet prochain